well coming up uh maz gibrani he is
coming to town and his special pandemic
warrior is now streaming on peacock and
this weekend he is bringing his things
are looking bright tour to the tropicana
yeah and jc fernandez chatted with a
comedian early today
when you have young kids at home from
the moment you wake up your whole goal
your whole goal is to make them tired
from the moment you wake up you're like
run run run
climb climb fly try fly you can fly
fly paint the house make the house maz
how are you buddy we're so happy that
you're coming to las vegas how you doing
man
i'm excited to be coming to vegas it's
been uh a while and uh i'm good how you
doing good you know i got a question for
you because the the jc stands for the j
stands for jorge so you know back to
school roll call was always a difficult
time for me because the teachers would
be like georgie jorge what was school
like for you gosh a lot of times i would
get mass
you know and uh to me mass is
fingernails on a chalkboard because it's
i always go and i'll tell people i go
it's ma it's like mazda mazatlan
maserati lamaze and they go okay and
then they go so mass and i'm like no and
then my last name is jobrani they come
in with jabroni i go no you messed it up
even more how has you know touring and
doing shows post pandemic or i guess a
lighter pandemic been for you
well i'll tell you the beginning of
whatever it was a few months back when
the people were getting vaccinated and
everyone thought oh we're back this is
it and i go to the comedy clubs here in
la and people were hugging each other
and excited and going this is amazing
we're back and the audiences were happy
and
everything felt great and then of course
quick quickly things slowed down because
we realized not everybody was getting
vaccinated a lot of people were getting
vaccinated and then the delta variant
and so we went back to like oh my god
keep your distance and here's what i
think i think the cause of it all jc
really i think it's because i named my
tour
things are looking bright
i think i jinxed the whole thing i just
jinxed it it was mine
i knew i spoke too soon i should have
said things might be looking bright but
most likely not because we're americans
and we're crazy and we're going to be
locked up again that's that's going to
be on the marquee this weekend that's
the new headline of the show so during
the whole lockdown thing here i'm in my
in my guest bedroom here and in my house
it's just my wife and i we've got the
two dogs so if there was any kind of
issue she would go upstairs i would go
downstairs i know you've got two kids
how was it for you to be like doing
lockdown with the family
so with the zoom school i said as soon
as it happened
my wife and kids were in the house all
the time zooming booming booming they
took over the house
everything i have they started taking so
i had a computer i had to give it to one
of my kids there was a printer i gave it
to another kid
everything i had they just took over and
i was i would say like i felt like i
used to have a family before the
lockdown once the lockdown happened i
would walk into the living room and
there's a different person in every
corner typing away it looked like an
internet startup company it was no
longer a family it was a we work space i
was i was living in a wework space jc
well you can see mazda ronnie this
weekend at the laugh factory now